[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go ahead and put our hands
together for our taco drummers
and our peacock ballerina
whoever flew in from orlando and brought
their humidity with it please take it
with you as soon as we're done here
good afternoon everyone and on behalf of
getting
its chairman kt lim and the entire
resort's world las vegas family
including president scott sabella
welcome to the newest fully integrated
resort
and the first major round of development
to be built on the las vegas strip
in more than a decade we know that
there's been tremendous excitement and
anticipation about the resort and its
offerings and we cannot wait
to finally unveil the property tonight
but before we begin today's celebration
we'd like to take a moment to
acknowledge some of our state and local
dignitaries
ladies and gentlemen governor steve
sisolak and first lady kathy assisolac
congresswoman dina titus
clark county commission chair marilyn
kirkpatrick
clark county commissioner tick secretary
clark county commissioners james gibson
michael naft
ross miller william mccurdy and justin
jones
lieutenant governor kate marshall nevada
treasurer zach
conning nevada attorney general aaron
ford
we'd also like to acknowledge district
attorney steve wilson sheriff joe
lombardo
clark county fire chief john steinbeck
and county manager yolanda
king we welcome and offer our
congratulations to our neighbor steve
hill
president and ceo of the las vegas vegas
convention and visitors authority
and all of the lvcva members who are
with us today
we're also pleased to welcome members of
the nevada state senate
and assembly members of the nevada
judiciary and members of the
of the winchester town advisory board
we're also pleased to welcome the nevada
gaming commissioners and the nevada
gaming control board members
supervisors and agents who join us today
and finally
we're pleased to welcome hilton's
president and ceo chris nasetta
hilton's executive committee and board
members in attendance and all of our
partners who brought the vision
of resorts world las vegas to life now
i'd like to introduce you to the
president of resorts world las vegas
someone
many of you already know from his
impressive career in the gaming business
here in las vegas
ladies and gentlemen mr scott sabella
[Music]
thank you brian and welcome everyone
i've been dreaming of this day for a
long time i've also had a few sleepless
nights about this day
but i truly think what we built here
speaks for itself
so i'll do my best to keep this short
and sweet like all of you we're anxious
to officially open
the doors when it was decided to build
and develop resorts world property here
in las vegas
our goal was to embody the unique blend
of legacy
and tradition with the essence of all
the destinations represented
across the resorts world brand combined
with the energy
and excitement of a modern integrated
resort
in the greatest gaming destination of
all time las vegas
and i'm happy to say that we
accomplished that
and we know we could not have done it on
our own
there are so many people that deserve
personal thanks
it would take me over an hour to thank
them all and i will extend my gratitude
to each and every one of them
however i would like to take a quick
moment to acknowledge some groups and
people
that were instrumental in getting our
doors open today
first the many hard-working members of
the clark county government
including the planning department the
public works department
the building department the fire
department and so many others
who contributions and work made this
project a reality
we would also like to recognize and
thank bill richardson and his associates
your experience management and guidance
resulted in building resorts world on
time
and on money and on budget
safety was our top priority and we
achieved our goal with having an
excellent safety record
not having one major incident on a
project of this magnitude
is truly remarkable this could not have
been accomplished without the dedication
and attention to detail from the
thousands of construction workers
in their trades i want to personally say
thank you to all of you
speaking of
speaking of construction we would not be
remiss if we did not acknowledge
governor steve sisolat
for recognizing the significance of our
project
and so many other construction projects
in southern nevada
new construction plays a major role in
the lifeblood of the southern nevada
economy
and designating construction workers
essential during the pandemic
allowed our project and others to
continue development create
jobs and finish on time thank you
governor
in that same vein we would like to thank
clark county commissioner
chair marilyn kirkpatrick and
commissioner tic
sigerbloom and all of their colleagues
for their leadership
during what was certainly has been one
of the most challenging moments
in our community's history thank you
to the board members and the staff of
the nevada gaming commission
and the nevada gaming control board
thank you for your efforts and diligence
in working with us throughout the
approval process
what you're going to see tonight is a
direct result of the expertise of paul
stillman
everyone on from stillman partners paul
your experience your knowledge of global
gaming architecture
design and development is unsurpassed
we were lucky to have you by our side as
we brought genting's vision
for resorts world las vegas to life
you've designed an
absolute masterpiece thank you paul
last but not certainly least i would
like to take this opportunity to thank
the man of the hour
our chairman kt lim our team this
project
in las vegas are the beneficiaries of
kt's tremendous leadership
vision and decades of experience in
global hospitality
on a personal level i truly value the
collaboration and his engagement
throughout the development process it
was a it has been a true honor
leading your las vegas team chairman
thank you
genting came into las vegas at a time of
transition
and has invested considerable time and
planning
to ensure that what you will see today
represents a world-class skinting brand
his family has built
from everyone in honor resorts las vegas
team
thank you chairman
we are all very excited for all of you
to see and experience firsthand all that
resorts world las vegas has to offer
so in closing i would like to offer a
quick road hack road map of highlights
you will not want to miss tonight first
resort world las vegas offers the
largest collection
of branded hilton experiences in the
world with thirty five
hundred rooms something you'll hear more
about from hilton's president
and see ceo chris nasetta shortly
second we have 117 000 square feet of
the latest
in gaming technology don't miss that
tonight
and for those of you here there those of
you you that are here for the food
we have more than 40 food beverage
concepts
so there is a treat and a flavor for
everyone tonight
las vegas has committed itself as a top
convention destination
and there will be no better place to do
business than resorts world las vegas
between our proximity to the las vegas
convention center
our connection to the las vegas loop as
the first resort
to have a passenger station and 250 000
square feet of meeting and banquet space
we have got you covered and we are open
for business
and for those of you with with some
spare room on your credit cards
please feel free to visit the district
we have gone to great lengths to ensure
there is something new and different to
the shopping experience
for all our guests at last but certainly
not least
the entertainment from an incredible
nightlife complex
by our partners at zoo group singapore's
top
like top nightlife lifestyle brand
to live entertainment venues like the
dog house
there will be no lack of entertainment
to offer
plus with the help of our partners of
concerts west
and aeg presents we will introduce some
of the biggest names
music to their new home at our theater
this fall
we could not be more thrilled to welcome
celine dion
carrie underwood katy perry and luke
bryan to the resort's world las vegas
family
as our founding headliners
so please explore enjoy and be
entertained
thank you for being our guest this
evening and i've been waiting a long
time to say this
welcome to resorts world las vegas thank
you
thank you scott i think you'd be
hard-pressed to find somebody any more
excited than scott here in just a little
bit
as i previously mentioned we are joined
this evening by some very special guests
including clark county commission chair
maryland kirkpatrick and commissioner
tick secretary we would like to invite
to come say a few words
just wanted to congratulate everyone and
just remind everybody that this didn't
just happen
if you asked a year ago if this would be
built right in the pandemic you would
have said no
but people came out here worked their
butts off pouted nails poured concrete
with masks on while we're home
complaining because we can't do zoom
so these guys really pushed them out and
then the other side is the county
employees who worked hand-in-hand to
review everything to prove everything so
we congratulate them to
thank them so much and here's our chair
who made it all happen
i really want to say thank you on behalf
of clark county and all
commissioners we'd really like to add a
special treat to today
we've worked long and hard we to get to
this day
it's exciting the tourists are back what
a better time to open a new casino
vegas is back we're ready for business
and i couldn't be more happy
so with that we would like to proclaim
two-day
resorts world las vegas day throughout
las vegas and the entire las vegas
valley
to start off so that we can get people
in here and enjoy it so on behalf of
clark county
congratulations for resorts world las
vegas
and good luck to all um your success
so thank you
thank you commissioners that's right
vegas is back my friends
governor sister lack has been an
advocate for our state and of jobs for
the people of nevada we're honored to
have him here and would like to invite
the governor of the state of nevada
up to say a few words governor
thank you i'm so excited i don't think i
need this microphone tonight
i want to begin by saying people say if
you dream it you can build it
you cannot dream what is inside these
walls it is so magnificent it is so
phenomenal so over the top it's setting
a new standard and it's raising the bar
very very high i want to thank all my
colleagues of the course at the county
commission and
in the county departments but
particularly to kt
and the entire limb family
the entire family have just been so
outstanding in terms of helping us
true you uh come out of this uh pandemic
and
the folks that have done a great job
scott savella is just scott we can't
thank you enough for what you did
what you're doing gerald gardner of
course for what he has done to be part
of this
and bill richardson and his partner of
atlanta and
paul steelman these are the people that
make things happen but
when we got to the pandemic it was well
first off i want to thank the
dance troupe that came when i was here
last time they were on groudon
just dirt and they were performing
you've come so far since that day
but i was here with it when we were
building and kt you just topped out the
facility and it was just
concrete slabs and no sides it was just
steel and concrete and
he took me up in his rickety
construction elevator to the very top
floor
and i've got my cell phone out taking
some pictures i'm standing way back in
the middle and he goes come on come on
over here to the side
and take some pictures he had no worry
whatsoever walked right up to the edge
and
i took mine from the middle of the floor
but when do we not shy of not liking
heights
when we got into the pandemic we faced
some tough choices and i want to thank
my colleagues my friends at the county
commission and the city and
and we had to deem some industries
essential workers
and i had several discussions with both
scott and gerald
and bill richardson and i didn't want to
put that many more people out of work
when we shut down the las vegas strip
because i knew we would emerge
from the pandemic and i knew we needed
to keep people working
during that time and there is no better
project
to keep people working on we built a
stadium a convention center and a
magnificent hotel
because construction workers went above
and beyond the men and women who pound
the nails
pour the concrete and hang the seal did
an absolutely remarkable job
on this property and the extra protocols
that were put into place
to keep people safe the safety record on
this project
is above reproach and again to set an
example for all of us
so with that we came out of the pandemic
we're getting better we're not finished
yet but we're getting better
and we've got this magnificent property
to propel us forward
and again special thanks to my friend kt
and the limb family for all that you've
done all you continue to do
you're an incredible part of our
community and on behalf of over three
million people
that call nevada home god bless you and
thank you very much for what you do
appreciate you thank you
thank you governor tonight we're joined
by our representative in congress who
has been working diligently
to help nevadas ladies and gentlemen
please welcome congresswoman dina titus
[Music]
thank you very much governor you're a
hard act to follow
in so many ways but at least i didn't
have to come after the beautiful peacock
dancer that would have been
too much i'm just honored to be here
with scott mr nasetta certainly our
chairman
thank you very much our county
commissioners and all of you
to celebrate the opening of this
fabulous resort
you know i often tell people i represent
the most
exciting district in the country and
this is one of the reasons you are
looking at it and you'll experience it
tonight
you know resort world has uh is an
amazing addition to the strip
creating thousands of jobs in
construction
hospitality food and fashion
what a way to tell the world that las
vegas
is back the opening couldn't have come
at a better time
and not only are we back but we are more
fun we are more exciting we are more
vibrant than ever and we are safer safe
for
our employees and say for our visitors
so help us spread that word
las vegas has always been a resilient
city
and this certainly proves that that's
the case so thank you governor for your
leadership
and your courage to help us out of this
pandemic and get our economy rolling
again
our county commissioners who use those
american recovery act dollars to fight
against
covid mr chairman thank you for having
faith in las vegas
thank hilton and scott for betting the
long game
here on all of us so from the 700 000
people i represent here in district one
we want to say thank you congratulations
and welcome to the neighborhood
thank you congresswoman we would like to
welcome chris nasetta president and ceo
of hilton
one of resort world las vegas's most
significant and well-known brand
partners
with 3 500 rooms across three premium
hilton brands
resorts world las vegas offers the
largest collection
of branded hilton experiences chris
thank you brian it is wonderful to see
such an extraordinary
crowd on an extraordinary evening to
celebrate
what i think we all know is an
extraordinary asset those that haven't
been inside we'll find that out
very very soon um more than a half a
century ago
baron hilton had a dream to see
vegas become the entertainment capital
of the world and he spent much of his
adult life
bringing that dream into reality
building on the strip
off the strip and we had a tremendous uh
presence in in vegas one of the last
things
sadly baron left this earth
in the latter part of 2019 i saw him a
couple of years before that
and one of the last things he said to me
as he left my office was
when are you going to get hilton back on
the strip
well hilton's back on the strip
and las vegas is indisputably
the entertainment capital of the world
and there is no
better asset than what sits behind me i
think to be a testament to that
at hilton all of us are extraordinarily
proud
to be part of this project we're proud
to be returning
to live the dream of our founder son and
be back on the strip
this is the largest property as you
heard that we'll have
in the entire world as you've heard from
many
uh it takes a village as i say every
time we open a hotel but when you open a
3 500 room hotel it's a bigger village
and so
many thanks go to everybody involved in
this incredible project
making it a reality all our state and
local officials who are
here with us today all the advisors and
architects and engineers
contractors and everybody else that
helped our hilton team many of
whom are here today i want to say a big
thank you to you and of course
resorts world and and genting who not
only
put this together but kt you and your
team
had the vision and the clarity of
purpose
in the toughest of times to see this
through
i couldn't tell you again how excited we
are to be here
the resorts world and genting family
lim family have been incredible partners
to us not just here but around the world
we had dinner last night talked about
that
these relationships are all about
partnership and friendship
and i know that at hilton we consider
this one of the most important
partnerships and friendships
that we have in the world we look
forward as we as i think we can all
agree to an incredibly successful
opening and more importantly many many
decades
of success together i said to scott when
we were walking through
last night i said the most amazing thing
about opening hotels is they never close
so starting tonight we'll probably never
see fewer than 20
000 people maybe 30 000 tonight in this
hotel
for the rest of our lives um it is a
living breathing being that has been
brought to life kt by you
and your family scott you and the team
again we couldn't be more proud to be
part of it
the last thing i want to say is we do
have a number of the hilton family with
us today if you guys could stand up and
just
say hello it's wonderful to have you
with us
carrying on baron's legacy thank you for
joining us tonight again thank you
everybody for being here
thank you so much chris uh our next
speaker is a man behind the strength of
the resort's world brand
and its parent company genting as
chairman
and chief executive genting kt lim is
integrally involved in the operations of
the various businesses that compromise
the genting group of companies with over
50 years of experience in development
and operation of destination resorts
around the world diversified interests
in agriculture
bioscience real estate as well as oil
gas exploration and production
genting is one of the world's top
businesses in addition to managing all
of those interests mr lim is also
responsible
for several premier brands and
relationships with the company's brand
partners
today as we officially open resorts
world las vegas
i have the distinct privilege to
introduce you to the man behind the
company
and its achievements ladies and
gentlemen mr kt
lim the chairman and chief executive of
genting
[Music]
well i like to start off by saying wow
what a beautiful performance
by our lion dance troupe
it was just a few short years
as the governor mentioned
that the same lion dance troupe
was performed on a piece of dirt
on the open car park
on the other side of the this
building
good evening and it is wonderful
to see all of you here in person
frankly i was worried that i may have to
do this
virtually because until
just 10 days ago we wasn't sure
whether we would be allowed to
travel freely between malaysia
and the united states
but thanks to the vaccination that we
received
we managed to make the trip here so
therefore this makes it the most happy
occasion
thank you too also very much for joining
us
on this very special and historic moment
for resortsville las vegas the newest
mega resort on the las vegas strip
back in 2013 when
genting berhan acquired
what was then the echelon site
our goal was to bring a new
and unique entertainment lifestyle
destination
to the las vegas strip and to showcase
what has made the resorts world brand
a globally recognized success
in the gaming world whilst
kovit 19 had set us back
it has also forced us to review
how we will work live
and play in the new world ahead of us
with our unique architecture and
state-of-the-art
design incorporating the latest
technology and digital displays
and artificial intelligence what we have
built
on the las vegas strip is not
only redefine its skyline
but set itself as an iconic
landmark for the next generation
of destination gaming results to follow
by partnering with hilton and
resortsville we are ready to showcase
the best in hospitality
fabulous shows and fantastic
entertainment
for all to enjoy
today is also a very special moment for
the genting group
as this is our latest
and largest resourceable property
to open with 3500
rooms this is the third mega resort
and the 11th resortsville property
to open under the resorts world brand
at over 4 billion dollars
it is also genting's single largest
investment in the united states to date
58 years ago my beloved father
and mentor the late tan sri lim gautam
who founded the genting group was
inspired to build a mountain holiday
resort
for all malaysians to enjoy
genting's first resort property
resourceful genting started construction
in 1964 and opened for business
in 1971 with a
200 room hotel
the resort has grown over the years to
become malaysia's
and asia's most successful
integrated resort and the premier
tourist destination in asia with over
10 000 rooms and the world's
single largest hotel attracting
over 20 million visitors annually
now resorts were las vegas which started
construction
in 2015 and opens today
is a momentous milestone that takes
place
exactly 50 years after construction
of our first resort in malaysia
i am confident that with the exceptional
team
and partnerships we have built in las
vegas
we can overcome all challenges
the next 50 years will be a journey
poised for growth and success
so much so governor
we are already planning the next phase
of resortsville las vegas
i'm happy that construction of the
resort
which employed over four thousand
workers
helped to sustain the local economy
during the difficult days of covet 19
pandemic today i'm proud to say that our
resort
provides close to 6 000
new jobs and career opportunities
that further support the local economy
ladies and gentlemen on this note
i wish to thank everyone who has worked
contributed or played a part
in our journey to create resourceful las
vegas
that you see in front of you today
a shout of thanks to all team members
from genting resorts world
and especially the hilton family
paul stillman richard bill richardson
and our many consultants suppliers
and contractors who work diligently
to meet not only the timeline
but the budget
to governor steve siselek
team nevada and team las vegas
have a heartfelt thanks
to everyone of you for the confidence
and support
that you have given us that made this
opening
possible today
a warm welcome also to steve hill
and the las vegas convention
and visitors authority for being our
very special
neighbor just across the road
do visit resortsville las vegas more
often
especially when the new and first
boring passenger station opens
right here on resortsville las vegas
most importantly i would like to thank
my beloved wife and family
without their support patience and love
it would not have been possible to
achieve
all that i have done to date
a special mention to my son brilliant
who as my trusted deputy and with
his zook and retail team members
have performed outstandingly
on the entertainment and foot fronts
as for the beautiful design and artwork
which you see around the resort i have
to thank
my youngest son louis lim and his
team for their fantastic creative inputs
to scott sebela and the resortable
las vegas team a big thank you
for your excellent work the many long
hours
spent in planning brainstorming
and working to get things done to
perfection
have paid off from what all of us can
see
with our own eyes the result we have
today
is a testimony of your good efforts
and keep it up the superb work as we
chant
the path ahead for our resort expansion
so don't think that you will get the
holiday
to our 6 000 new employees
welcome to the resortsville family
every one of you is hired for your
exceptional talent
and skills that you can bring
to our resort through all of you
we have a phenomenal team
the success of resort world las vegas
will be your achievement too
i believe we have what it takes
to make this resort a resounding
success one that can
propel us to a strong future
to everyone here who have come from near
or far a very big thank you
for your great support and friendship
my best wishes to all of you and i hope
you have you will have a fabulous time
at resortsville las vegas at this moment
i would like to acknowledge what
mr chris nesita has said
about baron hilton's
desire to return to las vegas
because even before chris
has heard it from baron i was
a person that baron has said
as told of his desire to return to las
vegas
so to that i would
thank in this memory the great
hilton family that together
with the lim family i think we can
achieve a great deal more
so to
christmas with her and this is what um
we said
we have something in private here
elvis is back in the house viva las
vegas
with results well
las vegas is truly back thank you
well thank you so much chairman lim and
you have come
a very long way from 200 rooms over
malaysia ladies and gentlemen
to bless our opening with luck and
prosperity please help me welcome
our lion and dragon
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
now ladies and gentlemen as is customary
in the asian tradition when you have
a lion ceremony the lions are asleep at
this point and what we're about to do
is call dotting the eyes what we're
going to do is we're going to dot them
with red paint representing blood life
and energy these lions are in turn going
to chase away any evil or negative
spirits so that we can usher in
blessings
and obviously a very prosperous opening
to join us over here
on the far side i'd like to ask the limb
family to come join us on the far line
over here to adopt those eyes
limb family
we're going to ask that you please grab
one of those brushes and dip it into the
red paint
and stand in front of your line
our next line will be chris nasetta ceo
of hilton chris if you can grab a brush
please
governor this slime is for you
and first lady caspian systelac joining
us as well
chairman lim if you can please grab your
brush i'm going to head over to the
other side
all right mr cebella go ahead and grab
that brush and come over to your line
congresswoman if you can come over
and commissioners please dip your
brushes in the ink and stand in front of
your line
and now we're going to begin this
ceremony
the sun rises from the east illuminating
our skies
please take your brush and dot the left
eye dot the left eye
please dot the right eye of your line
please dot the right eye
of your line
[Music]
and now please dot from head to tail for
good luck
and prosperity for all
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen our lions
are now gonna start to wake
[Music]
go ahead and feed those hung bao those
red envelopes into the mouth of the lion
for an auspicious opening for a
prosperous opening for good fortune
for good luck
all right if i can have all of our
executives to the front
come and join us
chairman lim and governor siselek come
up to the front
[Music]
yes
all right
all right so executives we're gonna get
okay all right come on over come on over
everyone's got their scissors
everyone look forward for the photo
well scott chairman you have permanently
changed the skyline of las vegas and you
are about to embark
onto the history of this city ladies and
gentlemen
let's go ahead and count them down for
the official opening
of results world las vegas in five
four three two
one
[Music]
[Music]
so
take a picture